qué tal bienvenido a la lista de
reproducción de estadísticas esto es
algo que llevo planeando hacer ya desde
hace algún tiempo pero bueno lo que
quiero hacer ahorita es entrar de lleno
en el tema quiero hacer algunos ejemplos
y con eso voy a intentar comunicarte la
idea de qué se trata esto de lo de la
estadística entonces pues para empezar
acordémonos de la idea intuitiva de la
estadística estadística intuitivamente
se trata de que si te dan muchos números
o muchos datos de alguna forma quieres
lograr entender los la estadística se
puede clasificar en dos categorías la
primera es estadística descriptiva la
estadística descriptiva se trata de que
si tienes mucha información o muchos
datos
quieres comunicárselo a alguien pero sin
darle toda la información por ejemplo lo
que puedes hacer es abreviar toda la
información en solo un número que de
alguna forma represente bien la
información
esto sería estadística descriptiva otra
rama es la estadística inferencial
estadística
esencial y aquí de lo que se trata es
después ya que tienes la información
sacas conclusiones por ejemplo lo que
puedes hacer es tomar una muestra de una
población y bueno luego vamos a hablar
más de muestras y poblaciones por el
momento te adelanto que no es lo mismo
entrevistar a tres personas que
entrevistar a toda la ciudad
las tres personas serían una muestra y
la ciudad la población pero bueno en
estadística inferencial lo que queremos
una vez que tomamos una muestra es
aplicarle matemáticas y de ahí poder
sacar inferencias o conclusiones de la
población total vale esto es un vistazo
de la clasificación pero ahora sí vamos
a entrar de lleno vamos a empezar con
estadística descriptiva con esta de acá
entonces la primera cosa que uno quiere
hacer o al menos que yo quisiera hacer o
que casi todos quisieran hacer cuando
tienen un montón de información así un
montón de numeritos es intentar dar un
solo número que de alguna forma describa
bien al conjunto es decir que sea pues
un indicador del de los números de la
muestra un número que representa la
tendencia central voy a escribir aquí
tendencia central porque este es un
concepto ya de estadística
tendencia central a la tendencia central
también se le conoce como promedio le
voy a poner aquí promedio y voy a hacer
un poco más preciso de lo que usualmente
soy cuando usó la palabra promedio
porque en este contexto el promedio
simplemente es algún número que de
alguna forma nos da pues más o menos una
idea de cómo es la tendencia central es
decir es un número que es más
representativo para un conjunto ahorita
vamos a hacer un poquito de ejemplos hay
muchas formas de definir un promedio o
bueno muchas formas de dar una medida de
la tendencia central a lo mejor ya las
has visto la primera es la media de
hecho o sabes que nada más nos vamos a
quedar con la media aritmética
aritmética quizás después cuando
hablemos de desigualdades o de otra cosa
hablaremos de la media geométrica o de
la media armónica o tal vez otras
también está la mediana la media mediana
y la moda ok en estadística todas estas
de aquí son ciertas medidas de la
tendencia central
ok son representativas de la pues de los
números de un conjunto todos estos de
aquí colectivamente pues nos dan más
información del conjunto ahorita vamos a
hacer algunos ejemplos pero antes una
aclaración casi siempre en la vida
diaria cuando alguien habla de un
promedio se refiere a la media
aritmética seguro esto ya te ha pasado
antes entonces cuando alguien te dice y
sácame el promedio de estos números lo
que quieren que encuentres es la media
aritmética no quiere ni la mediana ni la
moda pero bueno antes de seguir vamos a
hacer un pequeño ejemplo para entender
las definiciones voy a hacer una muestra
digamos que tenga a 1
a otro 1123
digamos un 4 y nada más así voy a
dejarlo así pequeño para ver las ideas
entonces la media
bueno la media aritmética la media
aritmética es probablemente con lo que
estás más familiarizado simplemente es
sumar todos los números y dividir entre
la cantidad de números que hay en este
caso nos quedaría 1 más 1 2 3 4 dividido
entre la cantidad de números o sea 1 2 3
4 5 entre 5 saber uno más uno es dos
luego dos más dos es 4 413 7 y 74 es 11
esto es igual a 11 quintos que es lo
mismo que 10 puntos más un quinto o sea
2 con un quinto que es igual a 2.2 ok
entonces pues fíjate este de aquí es un
pues buen representante del conjunto de
los números de acá porque todos estos
números se parecen al 2.2 representa la
tendencia central de este conjunto eso
de ahí usualmente lo llamaríamos el
promedio pero en estadística le llamamos
la media aritmética de este conjunto
y pues si lo representa bien si no te
quiero dar todos los números te puedo
dar el 2.2 y entonces más o menos te
puedes dar una idea de por dónde están
distribuidos los números después vamos a
hablar de qué tan lejos quedan los
números de la tendencia central esto lo
veremos en el próximo vídeo bueno esto
de que es una medida
otra medida es en vez de sumar y dividir
entre la cantidad lo que vamos a hacer
es poner los números en orden que ya
están entonces lo voy a poner aquí abajo
paso 1 ordenar los números
y paso número 2 ver cuál es el número
que está en medio entonces aquí hay 5
números y el número del medio es el 2
por qué pues porque hay 2 adelante y hay
2 atrás
ok entonces esto de aquí se le conoce
como la mediana y es muy fácil de
encontrar 1 ordenamos y 2 vemos que el
número queda en medio va entonces aquí
tenemos que la mediana del conjunto es 2
y 2 pues se parece mucho a 2.2 están muy
cercanas entre sí y pues no hay una
respuesta que sea la mejor de las dos o
sea simplemente son formas diferentes de
medir la tendencia central aquí la
mediana es 2 a lo mejor ahorita te estás
preguntando cómo le podemos hacer cuando
tenemos una cantidad par de números por
ejemplo qué tal que nuestra muestra
fuera pues 1
1 2 3 4 y 4 aquí que sucede ahorita no
hay un número que quede justo en medio
pues porque el 2 no funciona porque hay
2 antes y 3 después y el 3 no funciona
porque hay 2 después si 2 después y 3
antes entonces no hay ningún número que
quede exactamente a la mitad si nos pasa
esto y queremos encontrar la mediana lo
que hacemos es tomar los 2 de en medio y
esos 2 de enmedio le vamos a sacar su
media aritmética en este caso dos más
tres 2.5 quedaría que la mediana es
igual a 2.5 muy bien bueno vamos a
tachar este ejemplo porque ahorita no
quiero confundir un ejemplo con otro
entonces déjame tachar esto de aquí
entonces ya sabes si alguien te pide
sacar la mediana de una cantidad par de
números te tomas los dos del medio y los
promedios ahora recuerda que todo esto
simplemente son definiciones son
herramientas para entender un conjunto
de números no es como que alguien
levantó una piedra y dijo ay mira me
encontré fórmulas para entender el
universo
todas estas de aquí simplemente son
herramientas humanas
que nos inventamos para entender grandes
conjuntos de números a lo mejor este no
es grande verdad son cinco números pero
si tuviéramos cinco millones pues es muy
muy muy práctico poder abreviar lo a
sólo un número pero bueno ya que
hablamos de esto voy a pasar a la moda y
esto no tiene nada que ver ni con ropa
ni con zapatos de hecho casi toda la
gente se olvida de qué se trata la moda
en un examen y se confunden piensan que
es muy sofisticado pero en realidad es
algo muy fácil de encontrar la moda como
su nombre lo dice es lo que están
haciendo la mayoría de los números o
bueno en otras palabras es el número que
más se repite en nuestro conjunto en
este ejemplo hay dos unos y uno de cada
uno de los demás entonces la moda sería
uno muy bien entonces la moda es el
número que es más común en el conjunto
ya lo mejor pues puedes preguntarte qué
pasa si tenemos este ejemplo qué sucede
aquí pues hay dos unos y hay dos cuatros
y aquí es donde la moda pues se hace un
poco como truculenta porque tanto uno
como cuatro serían una respuesta
correcta para la moda 14 son
de este conjunto entonces pues esto se
puede volver un poquito ambiguo pero no
te preocupes en un examen yo creo que no
te va a pasar esto seguramente habrá un
número que se repita más
bueno ahora te has de estar preguntando
por qué nos quedamos con tres medidas en
vez de simplemente una porque no usamos
nada más la media aritmética digamos y
nos olvidamos de la mediana y la moda
pues déjame hacer un ejemplo para ver si
te puedo convencer de que puede que sí
es buena idea tener varias medidas
entonces vamos a tomar el siguiente
ejemplo vamos a tomar 33 3 3 3
y algo es medio raro digamos 100
entonces cuál es la media aritmética de
este conjunto la media 309 1215 tiene
115 entonces nos queda 115 dividido
entre 6
2 3 4 5 6 6 6 números ahora cuánto nos
da esto pues vamos a hacer la división
de casitas nos quedaría 115 entre 66
cabe una vez baja como 6 la resta y 5
baja el 5 caben nueve veces y sobra uno
verdad entonces es 19 con un sexto muy
bien lo que hicimos fue sacar la media
aritmética sumamos todos y dividimos
entre el total pero mi pregunta es este
número realmente representa al conjunto
es decir tenemos muchos 13 si un 100 de
repente y estamos diciendo que la
tendencia central es como 19 pero pues
no parece ser un muy buen indicador
claro depende del contexto pero parece
estar un poco desviado o sea yo creería
que debería estar un poco más cerca a 3
no sé tú qué piensas otra vez depende
del contexto vamos a la mediana la
mediana bueno los números ya están en
orden no hay que ordenarlos entonces
simplemente tenemos que ver cuál queda
la mitad pero como son 6 va a haber dos
que quedan a la mitad entonces son tres
y tres
ahora tenemos que promediar los o bueno
más bien sacarle su media aritmética
verdad
336 entre dos las tres muy bien entonces
esto de aquí tal vez es una mejor
aproximación para la tendencia central
de este conjunto de números pues no sé
por qué no se desvía tanto por el cien
si no sea simplemente como que este cien
queda por ahí y lo estamos más o menos
ignorando verdad este cien que queda tan
lejos lo vamos a llamar un valor extremo
ahora pues cuando sería un buen contexto
para usar medianas por ejemplo con
precios de casas o sea si damos por
ejemplo en este mismo ejemplo si decimos
que el precio medio es 19 millones
entonces puedes tener una muy mala idea
de él pues el precio de las casas de la
ciudad pero el precio mediano es 3
millones y eso te da un poquito más de
idea después cuánto van a costar las
casas de modo similar en este conjunto
la mediana nos da una mejor idea de por
dónde están los números lo malo de la
media fue que este 100 la desvió mucho
la media usualmente es muy sensible a
los valores extremos ahora a decir
verdad esto de los valores extremos
tiene su chiste es de esas cosas que se
ven a simple vista pero que son bien
difíciles de definir nos vamos a pensar
simplemente como
valores aberrantes finalmente pasemos a
la moda cuál es el número más común pues
hay 53 y hay un 100 entonces el número
más común es 3 entonces pues en este
caso cuando tenemos un valor extremo
tanto la mediana como la moda pues a lo
mejor son un indicador un poco mejor de
lo que queremos de lo que queremos
entender del contexto en el cual estamos
trabajando pero bueno realmente no
sabemos estos números de dónde viene en
verdad si son precios de casas nos
conviene la mediana y la moda pero no sé
a lo mejor hay un contexto en el que si
nos convenga a conocer la media
aritmética
por ejemplo en calificaciones o sea si
son calificaciones a lo mejor hay
alguien que sacó 100 y los demás sacaron
3 y conviene más decir que el promedio
del grupo de 19 con un sexto a que es 3
en fin con esto termino lo de la
tendencia central y en el siguiente
vídeo lo que vamos a ver es qué tanto se
alejan los números del promedio te
recomiendo mientras en lo que hago el
otro vídeo que vayas jugando un poquito
con estos conceptos que ya definimos
hace algunos ejemplos chiquitos para que
le vayan agarrando cada vez más la onda
nos vemos en el próximo vídeo